joining me today conservative party
Deputy chair Nikki Aiken labor MP Angela
Eagle City Trader turned equality
campaigner Gary Stevenson and from The
Institute of economic Affairs Annabelle
Denham today 2.1 billion pounds to level
up the UK we know where it's going but
will it work
if you look at the funding and you
compare it to the number of people that
live in each region the region that has
done the best in the amount of funding
per person is the north it's a one-off
pot of money that pits communities
against one another creates winners and
losers it's a hunger game style
competition
King Charles is giving some of his
millions back to the treasury should
more millionaires be made to do the same
this former city Trader thinks they
should for the good of the economy
and would you rather eat a burger made
of this
or this can lab-grown meat cure our
environmental woes
[Music]
let's start with a discrimination claim
brought by a former Deutsche Bank worker
who was nicknamed for her gray hair
Christine Lagarde Christine Lagarde is
the president of the European Central
Bank you can see her here rather than
the former Banker from Deutsche Bank who
has lost that discrimination claim it
wasn't the entire case that she
presented but the judge ruled that the
nickname or jokes about gray hair was
just part of the irritation of
day-to-day office life which
occasionally occurs is the judge right
is this the sort of comment that would
have been made in some of the places
where you worked as a city Trader and do
you think this woman had a case uh
really on jokes about being gray-haired
because she's older
there was definitely a lot of joking
like this when I was on the trading
floor um I was in my early 20s so I
definitely wasn't in my gray era at that
time
um I got teased quite a lot well I got
teased for it is the way that I took you
know I'm from pretty poor buck and I'm
from east London there's not many people
from my sort of background on the
trading floor nowadays but for me what
was important was even though I came
from that background and I talked how I
do they gave me a chance to trade
against everybody else and when they saw
that I was a better Trader than
everybody else I was the guy and I think
I've actually seen bigger problems after
that when I went to do a Master Oxford
since I've been in the media
people that speak like me are very
rarely used to talk about economics so
for me even though in the city I was
teased I was listened to whereas you
know I often question the media why
there are so few people with regional
accents who have experienced poverty
talking about economics I don't get
teased here but where are the voices and
what about older people as you say you
were in your 20s it was your accent
um you say that perhaps there weren't
many people speaking like you who are
economists do you think attitudes to
older people in the workplace in those
sorts of workplaces is a problem
you know a lot of people don't survive
into therefore no not as traders in
trading
um
I mean it's a to be honest it's a it's a
doggy dog world for everyone in that
space
um but the one thing I liked about
trading was you're judged on your
results so really whatever your
background if your results are good
that's what matters
all right well let's turn our attention
to wealth you heard in the headlines
King Charles multi-millionaire has asked
for a surge in profits from the crown
estate in offshore wind farms to be used
for what he called The Wider public good
so it would mean that some money set
aside for The Sovereign Grant you can
see here the headline in the times
king's crown estate Wind Farm to
generate a billion pounds for Britain it
would be set aside normally for The
Sovereign Grant which runs the Royal
household but in this case he's
suggesting it be retained by the
treasury and can be used for public
spending so should the rest of the rich
be doing something similar what do you
make of the king's decision announcement
today a good oh it's very generous of
him I wish I had a billion pounds I
could donate away and be able to afford
um but it's not enough it's not enough
in the last three years the government's
given out 700 billion pounds
that would be enough to give 14 000
pounds to every single adult in the
country
now if you're going to give up that
amount of money you need to do an
analysis of where that money is going to
end up you have to and at the beginning
of covert I was screaming out let's do
an analysis of who's going to end up
with the 700 billion pounds the
conservatives didn't do it labor didn't
do it the BBC didn't do it so I did it
and what I found out was that money was
going to overwhelmingly end up with the
richest people in society that's enough
money to give the richest 5 million
adults in this country a hundred and
forty thousand pounds each now you were
a millionaire you earned a million
pounds in your first two years
um you say as a Trader you've changed
your mind about how uh the world how
capitalism uh should work in the UK what
what what sort of triggered your damocin
conversion the way I became a
millionaire is after the 2008 crisis
I realized that because of a massive
growth inequality
we would basically never come out of
that crisis and I started to put massive
bets on that the economy would get worse
and worse and worse and within a year of
doing that I became citibank's most
profitable Trader in the world so you
know if your job is to look at the
economy and analyze it and your analysis
is the economy is going to get worse and
worse because of inequality and they
knew what it does to be the best Trader
in the world I think it you have a
responsibility to do something about it
Civics would say that's after you earned
all that money uh that that was 25 you
know you could give me a bit of time
um
this is let's not forget money that has
been taxed on acquisition that you are
then looking at taxing further well what
are the policies going what would you do
lots of things are difficult but some
things are important okay if you give
out 700 billion pounds you need to know
where that money's gone to okay if
you're giving hundreds of thousands of
pounds to the richest people in the
country you have to expect inflation
a cost of living Christ for ordinary
people listen we increased inequality at
the fastest rate in the history of this
country during a time when the economy
was closed you are making ordinary
families poorer that is the cause of
this crisis just to explain you're
talking about hundreds of billions of
pounds being handed out during the
pandemic in part so during the furlough
scheme the argument from the government
um and I'll let Nikki and Angela uh in
in a moment was that it kept the it kept
people's jobs it paid people's wages
what were they to do instead
you do the analysis where the money will
end up listen I was there I'm an
inequality Economist I wanted to know
where does it end up okay the money goes
to follow the workers it's 14 000 pounds
per adult do you think furloughed
workers are 14 000 pounds richer they're
not because they weren't getting their
wages okay well who's got the wages the
corporations what were the corporations
Rich up in general not because they were
closed who's got the money the customers
but not all customers because it was
only luxury non-essential spending that
stopped during coven Nikki do you want
to uh defend furlough and the decisions
made by the government during that time
of course there are lots of allegations
about billions being wasted I'm not
against furlough what I'm against is not
analyzing where the money ended up and
not doing anything about it accumulating
with the richest people well they would
say there wasn't enough time to do it
but Nikki
there is an increase in the more the
wealthy paying more taxes I pay tax I
pay yeah exactly where can people pay
taxes the wealthiest people don't pay
tax they've been much much lower rates
of tax right and why is that is that
because they can afford to move their
money elsewhere is it because they can
afford to leave the country you know
what I might question it's partially
because we have a prime minister whose
father know is one of the richest men in
the world we have a previous prime
minister who wanted to make millions of
pounds as soon as he left office they've
come and made 10 million pounds in a
year of leaving office if you put tax
decisions in the hands of people who are
extremely rich or about to become
extremely rich do you think they will
say Lex that's extremely rich people all
right Nikki I think that's a cheap shot
keep keep throwing at the Prime Minister
you know he comes from the background he
comes from he's worked hard like you in
the city and you know he's made his
contribution and he's presiding over
there
I'm a low tax small state conservative
and I want to see tax cuts and you know
and I'm not coming are they well let's
see what's happened let's look let's see
what happens in the budget let's see
what happens in the next budget no we've
got we've we've got we've got to we've
got to move the move our growth agenda
on of course but we've also got to
ensure that we pay for covert we pay for
the cost of living and we ensure that we
pay for the war that's in Ukraine what
do you say to James Dyson I mean he is a
wealth Creator he would say
um and he doesn't want regulation and
high taxes in order to create jobs and
pay those people well I've never met
James Dyson he might be a very nice he's
a very wealthy person and he doesn't
want tax on the very wealthy I don't
think I need to say more than that but
what I'm saying is what I'm seeing from
this discussion is a government that's
giving out 700 billion pounds and has
done no analysis well you've said that
but you don't even know who's got the
money now but you left your job in the
city trading in 2014. more broadly
speaking what is the answer what are the
policies that either labor or
conservatives could do that would
actually bring back some of the way
wealth from the super rich if we're
going to call them that and redistribute
it there are some low-hanging fruit
which should obviously be done you
should equate capital gains with income
tax there's no reason why the wealthy
Pay Less on that on that rate you should
close the loopholes obviously but you
need to bring in something that will
transfer that wealth back if you do not
if you're willing to give 700 billion
pounds to riches and do nothing to bring
it back then ordinary families pay the
price so you need to bring in serious
moves to read this you've got to deal
with offshore tax evasions you've got to
deal with these packages of offshore
companies that allow people to export
their money and avoid paying taxes
you've got to deal with profit shifting
in global multinational corporations
some of this has got to be done by
International agreement but the fact is
as Thomas picketty The Economist says
we're now in a situation where the
wealthy are going to get more and more
wealthy and wealth is actually going to
accumulate without stopping because
growth levels are lower than the amount
of money you can get on on on
on your wealth in interest and it's
happening is that the billionaires index
the Bloomberg billionaires index has to
be updated every day well I mean
Annabelle isn't there before
billionaires wealth is rising so much
it's obscene and we need to as an Global
International Community of of of
politicians and economists do something
about it right
if the lives of the poorest are being
improved continually improved
um then even if the the super rich are
getting richer you're still seeing
improvements in the quality of life of
the poorest in society this is not about
inequality this is about living
standards of the ordinary people of this
country if you give 700 billion pounds
to the richest people in the country
when the economy is closed they will
spend that money drive up prices and
ordinary families increasingly will not
be able to afford the basics like food
and energy listen if you give this money
to the rich it affects Ordinary People
so what is your solution
a wealth tax in full spending listen do
you not accept that all of the downsides
to wealth taxes the fact that they're
almost everywhere that they've been
tried they've specifically you're
talking to somebody who has made
millions of pounds by betting that the
economy will collapse every single year
okay and I'm betting on that right now
and I don't want it to happen if you do
nothing about growing inequality if you
don't do anything about growing
inequality poverty will get worse and
worse and worse they're not telling you
now listen all right in a few years time
when it happens when things are worse
remember this day it's not and you can't
say you didn't know about sustainable to
run a global economy with this level of
inequality it's not economically
sustainable because there aren't enough
consumers with enough money to make the
economy work so it's not fair in any way
at the facts we have come through a a
pandemic when we spent 400 billion
pounds I do not think we should allow
our children and our grandchildren to
pay that debt and we've now got a cost
of living crisis basically because of
the energy crisis and the government has
put billions of pounds into supporting
particularly the most vulnerable over
the over now over the last few months
and moving forward but I think about
wealth tax we should not be creating
more tax we should be cutting so all
right well you're very clear on that
we're going to talk about something else
which is sort of related leveling up
it's the great Mantra of uh Boris
Johnson and continues under Rishi soon
now more than 100 schemes it's been
announced today have won Government
funding in the second phase of the
leveling up fund it's worth about 2.1
billion pounds it's not an insignificant
amount of money let's give you an idea
about how how it's going to be spent
some of it
so openly boasted about taking money off
labor held errors and giving them to
talk he did in a video he said that
there are poorer areas in parts of the
country that are broadly affluent but
even in the Southeast there are poorer
uh poorer areas that need funding is it
a good idea is this going to transform
people's lives in these areas
well I mean if I take 15 part of you and
then give you two pound 80 is that going
to transform your life
these guys they've found 2.8 billion
pounds to give to local councils in the
last three years they're given 700
billion pounds to the richest now you've
met 50 times as much listen is it
leveling up if I give a poor person two
pound 80 and I give a rich person 250
pounds no sorry 700 pounds 250 times as
much listen
this government has presided over the
largest and fastest ever increased
inequality in the history of the country
and the most orwellian thing you've ever
heard they call that leveling up
what do you say I think in this case
we're talking about relatively trivial
amounts of money for projects that often
ought to be financed by the private
sector
but finally local Authority budgets have
been cut I mean Angela is right over the
years over the years they they have been
cut have you had complaints from
conservative colleagues who haven't got
money after being asked to promote this
uh I haven't spoken to anybody about it
either way right so no one's come to you
and complain all right well let's move
on let's talk about something completely
different Annabelle you have a new
report out from The Institute of
economic Affairs to do with lab-grown
meat tell us about it sure um I think
the first thing to say is that although
the sales are something in the realm of
Science Fiction it is underway but is
nonetheless very much in the early days
so
that is surely more friendly for the
environment and is currently across the
world all right well let me ask our
other guests what do you think about uh
deregulating uh lab-grown meat would you
eat a lab-grown burger I'll give it a go
I don't mind my main thought is you know
I think it's very interesting that the
iea The Institute of economic affairs
has a chance to come on a show like this
and talk about a disaster in the economy
that that partially they caused by
inspiring literacy economic policies
which are disaster and instead of
grabbing the ball by the horns and
talking about this disaster which is
damaging tens of millions of people's
lives they ask us to talk about
lab-grown meat and what do you think
about him about lab-grown me about the
iea but well you've done the Ia about
lab grow about you're not a fan of
either
Technical Solutions are they not to be
considered uh properly when we're
looking at things like climate change in
the environment
yeah for sure if they work if they work
if they just how will you know if they
if they work unless you try them well I
think you should give them a go but if
you're just using them to distract me
your own disastrous economic advice then
I think it's probably not a good idea
um that's all for today I'm exhausted
but thank you very much to all of our
guests I will be back tomorrow with
politics UK at 12 15 here on bbc2 and on
the BBC iPlayer bye-bye